I feel such a huge piece is just missing
for me so you guys were like married no
I know we were our life's just one Nikki
Bella dropping the bombshell news on
sister breeze that she and John Cena
decided to call off their wedding all
playing out in this sneak peak clip of
Sunday's new episode of total Bella's
even breathe who hasn't always been
John's biggest fan gets emotional I just
want him to be like lonely and I don't
want him to like regret not being in dad
and John feels like a brother
and I hate thinking in my head that he's
gonna be alone makes me so sick then the
heartbreaking comment John made in
regards to Nikki one day becoming a mom
he sent me like this text last night and
he goes the day you become a mom and
look at your baby he goes I'm expecting
to get the first thank you text but it's
like I wanted him to be the father of my
kids well John has been adamant about
not wanting kids since day one
it seems he may have had a change of
heart since splitting from Bella here's
what he told The Today Show earlier this
month I'm willing to go back on all of
these things that I say and a lot of
them I was hanging on to just of
stubbornness yeah I won't have kids and
it took a very strong look in the mirror
for me to be like why this person is my
number one and it's something that's
very valuable to her and of course we
can do this all of that switched because
I love her
[Music]
[Applause]